welcome to this video and he's not
moving all right yeah are you going to
move all right let's see what happened
aha Joe Graham was even a surname in
them No ah the same ish what am I
playing against this I think our place
e5 n turn knight c6 yeah I'm a book i'm
recommending the main line against the
sameish with b6 and bishop asics Knight
f3 this is some slightly rare set up
it's not bad but it's rarely played this
is a bit like the hoopin online in the
Rubenstein system but with a 3 castling
is actually slightly weird if you go for
an early a three you should shouldn't
castle okay but it's not not the end of
the world obviously okay mmm yep can
play age six if you want Oh looky a
droopy eight is a bit silly Queenie 7s a
move but after d5 I don't have a square
yeah I can play h6 amongst others ok so
now known i th or first 96 night g6
so not clear I want to play a five let's
start this way if I move my knight on f6
it might play night each form to prevent
it some night you ate night each form
and I'm thinking about if i should play
night g6 first can do that it's not bad
okay let's prepare 5k night to g6 use
going to play night f5 or does this is
interesting anyway thinking about night
f form yeah it's quite quite interesting
let's let's do that
maybe taking one f4 is good no Oh
surprising the surprise me that he
allows this transformation
this looks some in my eye fairly good
for black 2794 is the threat yeah is
preparing g4 I should counter this with
e four so G 4 I go fo until he prevents
it I can even play you for now it's not
not bad at all but ok I probably this is
better g44 so ok
open to stroke the 78 intending e4 it's
not so easy to prevent it in the long
run
andrew p 8 mm no this this looks really
good for black isn't it I know does
doesn't it not isn't it doesn't it
doesn't it look good for black I'm
getting if orange and have his full of
holes this position Queenie 70 Queenie
87 probably I could have kicked the
check first maybe this was better first
the check ian was probably better yeah
okay if I take now it's probably not so
convincing I can take c3 though I can I
can exchange simply an ID hate you ok
but this probably weighed 98 is maybe
not so bad f6 King to e7 that at the end
I'm playing against their football yeah
I intend to cover yeah come over here
and cavity six and then at the end try
to get the a for prom with night c7a 8b
6 this is this maneuver g5 I go age five
okay Anita fix the weakness and now
night c7 back to be see all the way to
be six
I do not allow any entry squares like a
3g for each 50 after a capture it's not
realistic what it's not going to the
Queen scientists interesting how do you
defend this I mean maybe there was no
defense as possible
yeah this is fairly easy now even I just
take it and then return with the the
knight to e5 oh wait wait wait wait and
I can I can play here you he's better
check check winning all the pawns um how
to get get to to the f porn here you for
Mary J
mmm wait just just a minute here isn't
that way to get to this is not easy for
Paul and I don't see it
I'm not seeing an easy win at the moment
he's pretty active bishop we don't want
King c7 I could have played d5 and King
d6 this is what I should have done but
it's still possible and King g65 this is
the way to go yeah this wasn't the
greatest technical play ever but it
should be enough time for check check
yeah preme good display of the chances
that black is got in the Sun in this
closed position it was rather we had all
this I mean I didn't really get King a
three year old but he's probably not
able to defend it anyway can go play
like this but there's also this idea at
some point and also night c 8 is heaven
f5 yeah this C 875 just grabbing the
pond yeah you cannot really trade into
this kind of endgame at some material
weakened himself so much that it was it
was difficult him not to trade queens
yeah I think actually you should a wide
g5 but hear this this is really enough
achievement for black and this is made
me lost already it's hard for him to to
come all this night to be 6 and see 87
f5 it's I think it's indefensible the
computers on minus to that sees the the
pawn dropping already alright thanks for
watching